la poubelle
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur france 3
la chaîne des élections soirée
exceptionnelle ce soir ici au palais des
congrès de beaune
france 3 a créé l'événement en
réunissant pour la première fois les
sept têtes de liste de bourgogne franche
comté à 90 minutes de débat avant le
premier tour des régionales dans onze
jours exactement une émission en
partenariat avec france bleu
tomas genou gaillon est avec nous pour
relayer les questions des auditeurs
et bien sûr avec nous aussi jérémy
chevreuil pour faire jérémy bonsoir elsa
bonsoir à tous je vais tout de suite
vous présenter les sept prétendants à la
présidence du conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté
sept candidats de gauche à droite alors
pas l'échiquier politique sur la scène
de ce palais des congrès de beaune denis
thuriau vous êtes membre de la
république en marche votre liste
s'intitule la région partout et pour
tous bastien photos de la gauche
républicaine et socialistes pour la
liste le temps des cerises stéphanie
modde d'europe écologie les verts vous
mener la liste écologiste et solidaire
gilles platret les républicains vous
mener la liste pour la bourgogne et la
franche comté à vos côtés claire rocher
de lutte ouvrière pour la liste faire
entendre le camp des travailleurs
marie-guite dufay du parti socialiste
candidate de la liste notre région par
coeur et julien odoul du rassemblement
national pour la liste pour une région
qui vous protège
bonjour à tous les sets alors madame
messieurs ce soir je vous précise que
comme nous l'imposent le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel vous serez
interrogées selon la règle de l'équité
des temps de parole et puis pour vous
qui nous regarde et vous pouvez
commenter ce débat cette émission en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
mot dias qui s'affiche reg bfc comme
régional bourgogne franche comté alors
on va vous intéressez vous interroger
sur la jeunesse sur l'emploi mais aussi
sur l'environnement
on vous fera réagir aussi tout à l'heure
à notre grand sondage m est d'abord
première question question classique
pourquoi vous présentez-vous j'ai une
autre
c'est vous que le tirage au sort a
désigné pour commencer vous avez 48 ans
vous avez été journaliste écrit
plusieurs ouvrages historiques
vous êtes le maire ait l'air de la ville
de chalon sur saône également élu au
conseil régional pourquoi en briguer
vous la présidence tout simplement parce
que je souhaite avec l'équipe que nous
avons constitué sur la base un très
large rassemblement de la droite du
centre et des écologistes indépendants
redonner la fierté à la bourgogne et la
franche-comté la fusion n'a pas été une
réussite
elle a augmenté les impôts elle a
augmenté les dépenses de fonctionnement
et nous voulons aujourd'hui faire en
sorte que la bourgogne soit traité avec
des élus bourguignons que la franche
comté soit traité avec des élus franc
comtois rapprocher la région des
citoyens là où elle s'en est
terriblement éloignés c'est pour nous
une priorité absolue et nous y mettrons
tout notre coeur pour défendre des
thématiques qui aujourd'hui sont très
peu défendu dans la région la sécurité
qui est la grande absente et qui
pourtant une préoccupation première
la santé l'emploi est évidemment le
développement durable mais notre enjeu
c'est la proximité claire resserre vous
avez 41 ans vous êtes infirmière au chu
de dix jours vous étiez déjà candidate
en 2010 puis en 2015 pourquoi une
nouvelle fois j'ai passé sept années de
mon activité professionnelle en
réanimation qu'ovide et ce qui était
frappant cette année ce sont les
caissières les livreurs les travailleurs
d'usiné d'ailleurs qui ont continué à
aller travailler
lorsque le virus avait obligé à tout
arrêter et qui ont permis que les choses
continuent à fonctionner nous sommes
ceux qui faisons fonctionner cette
société est là dans ces élections
régionales fini les héros on voudrait
que nos intérêts vitaux qui sont d'avoir
un emploi d'avoir les moyens de vivre
avec notre salaire passe derrière les
intérêts et les préoccupations
notables et d'une minorité de
politiciens et moi c'est sur ces
nécessités vitales que je pense que le
camp des travailleurs doit se faire
entendre
nous devons nous battre pour sauver
notre peau face à une classe dirigeante
qui veut nous faire payer une crise
parce que nous faisons payer
justement parce que nous faisons
fonctionner cette société nous aurons la
force de le faire si nous en prenant
conscience et c'est le sens de ma liste
stéphanie modde vous avez 52 ans vous
êtes conseiller à pôle emploi vous êtes
élue municipale d'opposition à dijon
pourquoi êtes vous candidat à ces
élections régionales parce que l'urgence
sociale l'urgence climatique n'attendent
pas pour gagner la bataille du climat en
bourgogne franche comté il est
nécessaire d'avoir un programme
écologiste ambitieux c'est ma liste
d'union des partis écologistes qui porte
ce programme c'est nous qui avons les
solutions pour vous permettre de mieux
vivre de vous déplacer plus facilement
de vous nourrir sainement de travailler
ou d'étudier localement quel que soit
votre lieu de vie en bourgogne france
comté qui vous raconter une petite
histoire c'est celle de victor costa
café partie des citoyens
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
il a contribué à l'écriture des 150
propositions
ces propositions que le président de la
république a balayé d'un revers de main
alors victor costa a compris qu'on se
moquait urgence climatique et des
générations futures
il a compris que c'est l'inaction des
politiques depuis des années qu'ils
étaient punitive pour notre avenir
proche
aujourd'hui victor costa a décidé d'être
candidat il est sur ma liste dans
l'yonne voilà la raison de ma
candidature et celle de mes colistiers
pour une écologie de l'action
marie-guite dufay vous avez 72 ans vous
êtes présidente socialiste sortante vous
avez travaillé à la mp 1 dans la
formation professionnelle et l'insertion
notamment pourquoi pour présenter vous
parce que nous venons de traverser une
crise sans précédent pour laquelle nous
avons cherché à concilier une solidarité
absolument nécessaire avec tous les
acteurs touchés par cette crise et puis
en même temps l'innovation pour rebondir
et sortir de cette crise et les choses
ne sont pas terminées aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on respire
neuf points mais les taux même s'il
serait se resserre doit nous devons
avoir toujours une très très grande
vigilance
ce n'est pas le moment de quitter le cap
et c'est pour cela que je veux continuer
des politiques qui concilie solidarité
et innovation qui concilie développement
des territoires ruraux développement des
villes j'ai envie j'aime cette région
j'aime le travail ou la complexité est
au coeur et on en même temps il faut
écouter partager pour construire bastien
photo vous avez 43 ans vous avez
travaillé pour des collectivités des
organismes publics vous êtes aujourd'hui
lui d'opposition au département et à la
ville de belfort
pourquoi êtes vous candidat aux
élections régionales vient le temps des
cerises signifie le retour du printemps
après une longue année sans été un long
hiver qui a gelé les relations sociales
qui a frappé durement notre économie et
qui a détruit des emplois par centaines
de milliers dans notre pays et face à
cette crise qui n'a malheureusement pas
trouvé de solution durable de la part du
gouvernement parce qu'il continuait de
maltraiter notre système de santé et
notre système de solidarité nationale
eh bien nous avons jugé utile d'envoyer
un signal fort au coeur de la gauche
alors j'ai accepté de conduire cette
belle liste du temps des cerises
une liste qui rassemble aujourd'hui neuf
organisations politiques mais aussi des
soutiens plus large qui viennent
ailleurs au coeur de la gauche il s'agit
pour nous de relever les défis du temps
ces défis qui sont devant nous et de
remettre l'humain au coeur de l'ensemble
des politiques publiques en bourgogne
franche comté
donc on veut construire une majorité
nouvelle élargi au service du
redressement de notre région julien
dollars vous avez 37 ans vous êtes
attaché parlementaire conseiller
régional sortant élu municipal
d'opposition à sens pourquoi êtes vous
candidat à la présidence de la bombe et
de franche comté
j'aime passionnément notre région depuis
que ma grand mère me l'a fait découvrir
il ya près de 30 ans fait maintenant six
ans que je suis engagé politiquement en
bourgogne franche comté la fusion
finalement
à uré eurent réussi à me faire aimer
aussi la franche comté et ça fait six
ans que je me bats notamment pour
protéger la région protéger à la fois la
sécurité protéger nos emplois protéger
notre environnement nos terroirs notre
identité protéger l'avenir de notre
jeunesse
et je suis aussi candidat pour protéger
tous les oubliés tous les déclassés tous
les mépriser de la région que ce soit
les ouvriers et salariés précaires les
artisans les commerçants les
agriculteurs tous ceux qui incarnent la
région et tous ceux qu'on n'entend pas
je suis candidat pour incarner cette
alternance alternance dont nous avons
besoin qui est un une bouffée d'air
démocratique
je peux encore une fois faire gagner
cette alternance je suis le seul en
capacité de mettre un terme à 17 ans de
gestion socialiste
les électeurs peuvent me faire confiance
et enfin denis thuriau vous avez 54 ans
vous êtes avocat vous êtes maire de
nevers pourquoi êtes vous candidat à
cette élection régionale
je veux faire de la bourgogne franche
comté une région de la relance des
relances en lien avec l'êta et à l'état
qui était particulièrement auteurs
notamment sur point économique allait
également chercher une relance au niveau
des fonds européens pour sortir de cette
dualité dijon besançon qui sacrifient
les projets des territoires je veux être
le candidat de tous les territoires
parce que je sais ce que c'est parfois
d'être au fond d'une salle bien loin et
levez la main sans parfois être entendu
je veux être un président maire de
région dans l'esprit et aux côtés des
élus locaux aux élus des antilles aux
côtés des entreprises aux côtés de nos
concitoyens je suis le seul candidat à
être mère mais vous l'avez oublié
présidents d'intercommunalités sais je
porte l'économie depuis sept ans avec la
région et je sais les carences qu'il ya
parfois une région qui sera plus
présente à une heure de chacun avec un
défi que je donne connaître le nom de
ses conseillers régionaux la fin de mon
mandat je défie quiconque de les donner
aujourd'hui c'est révélateur d'une
absence de la région de proximité près
de tous et la région partout et pour
tous
elle sera à côté de chacun des habitants
merci madame messieurs pour ce premier
tour de table premier thème de ce débat
nous avons choisi de vous demander ce
que vous comptiez fier pour la jeunesse
de bourgogne franche comté la région a
en charge les
ici la formation professionnelle
notamment les jeunes vous le savez ont
été particulièrement touchés par la
crise sanitaire ces derniers mois crise
qui les en empêcher d'étudier dans de
bonnes conditions notamment
alors en quoi la région peut-elle aider
les jeunes au quotidien
marie-guite dufay vous commencez la les
jeunes les jeunes ya beaucoup de jeunes
il ya les lycéens et les étudiants il ya
les actifs il ya les jeunes agriculteurs
ja les jeunes demandeurs d'emploi
donc pour les lycéens c'est investir
massivement pour des lycées modernes
numérisés accessible à toutes les
familles y compris les plus modestes par
des tarifications sur l'internât et les
comptines c'est mettre le paquet pour
construire des outils pédagogiques qui
parle aux jeunes pour leur orientation
pour les faire pénétrer dans la réalité
des métiers de demain et dans la réalité
des métiers tout court
donc c'est une orientation renouvelée
dans les lycées nous lutterons aussi
contre la précarité menstruel les
étudiants et bien les étudiants nous
construirons une plateforme régionale
des stages parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une inégalité d'accès des lycéens comme
des étudiants aux stages dans les
entreprises
nous construirons une plateforme pour
les jeunes demandeurs d'emploi
c'est un partenariat extrêmement actif
avec pôle emploi et avec la mission
locale qui nous permettra d'adapter les
formations dans ce temps de crise et de
difficultés que nous connaissons il y à
aussi malheureusement des jeunes qui
décrochent
ils sortent de l'école sans aucun
diplôme
ils ont échoué dans leur scolarité et il
faut leur faire retrouver un autre
chemin de réussite pour cela il ya des
écoles que nous multiplierons ça
s'appelle écoles de la production ça
s'appelle écoles de la deuxième chance
et puis il y a les jeunes agriculteurs
les agriculteurs nous leurs finances ont
une dotation d'installation grâce à des
fonds européens
il ya là un enjeu extraordinaire pour le
renouvellement des générations en
agriculture
ces fonds européens vont baisser nous
les compenseront pour que cette dotation
ne baisse pas et de façon plus générale
du général pour tous les jeunes
la région qui avait mis en place une
art avantages jeunes avec des avantages
multiples à ajoutera dans cette carte 24
déplacements gratuits par an et je
souhaiterais je termine je souhaiterais
vous aurez à part la cour de ce qu'on
vous donnera la parole marie guinée fait
je vous promets une convention citoyenne
avec les jeunes pour mieux les associer
à la conduite de nos politiques gilles
platret quelles mesures prioritaires
pour nos jeunes au quotidien
quand on parle des jeunes est d'ailleurs
madame buffet on a fait l'expérience
on parle d'un public très large
comment définir a priori toutes les
politiques à mettre en place pendant des
années la priorité c'est d'abord de
donner la parole aux jeunes et nous nous
l'avons fait dans le cadre de cette
campagne
puisqu'une cinquantaine de jeunes depuis
le mois de septembre de l'année dernière
ont travaillé avec nous sur leurs
priorités ce qui leur semblait important
pour demain pour leur avenir et pour
leur présent aussi est ce que nous
voulons c'est prolonger cette expérience
là nous créerons demain pour commencer
un conseil régional des jeunes
c'est une instance où les jeunes les
différents jeunes justement comme il
vient d'être dit seront représentés pour
épauler les élus pour les asticoter
quand c'est nécessaire quand ils vont
pas dans la bonne direction
et aussi pour leur dire voilà où nous
souhaiterions que vous allez donc ça me
paraît absolument essentiel autour de ça
évidemment on a dégagé un certain nombre
de problématiques
d'abord vous l'avez rappelé la région à
la gestion des lycées or les lycées ne
sont toujours pas sécurisée et pourtant
dieu sait que ce n'est pas faute de
l'avoir demandée dans l'opposition à la
majorité sortante pendant des années
donc nous veillerons à ce que les jeunes
aient de bonnes conditions d'éducation
vidéo protéger les lycées apaiser les
tensions quand il y en a à dieu merci ça
n'est pas partout mais il y en a parfois
lutter contre les dangers sanitaires
moi je suis frappé que personne n'ait eu
envie d'imiter ses deux bonnes
expériences dauven rhône alpes avec
laurent wauquiez des purificateurs d'air
dans les salles de cours
donc nous autres on nous laissait dès la
rentrée qui vient et nous permettront
d'ailleurs aux communes qui
souhaiteraient avoir un fonds de
concours de la région de pouvoir le
faire également en direction des écoles
reprendre une vie normale
ouvrir les lycées aussi le soir lorsque
ya plus court ou pendant les vacances
pour que les équipements sportifs
puissent demain servir au plus grand
nombre et aux jeunes en particulier
donc il ya tout un enjeu de vie lycéenne
et j'ajouterais parce que je vous vois
en train de me faire de grands gestes et
j'ai bien content
qu'il fallait que je conclus nous avons
un enjeu extraordinaires en matière
d'orientation professionnelle
elle a été sacrifié dans ce monde à 0,7
pour cent du budget général à
l'orientation professionnelle
je me promène je pense que mes collègues
candidats le fond de la même façon
partout nous rencontrons plein de chefs
d'entreprise qui nous disent nous ne
trouvons pas de main d'oeuvre qualifiée
alors que nous avons dans la région 20%
des jeunes au chômage donc demain il ya
un enjeu énorme de faire rentrer les
entreprises dans le milieu scolaire pour
que ce soit même d'ailleurs des jeunes
qui viennent de rentrer dans la vie
active qui disent aux jeunes lycéens et
même en collaboration et d'appartements
aux collégiens quelles sont les filières
qui recrutent
bastien faut donc vos priorités pour la
jeunesse - d'abord je pense que ça doit
être désigné dès maintenant comme la
grande cause de ce mandat
pas pour de la com parce qu'en réalité
il faut voir que nous sommes la seule
région qui vieillit aujourd'hui dans le
pays est une région dans laquelle le
chômage des jeunes a beaucoup augmenté
pendant la crise alors la question
centrale qui est devant nous c'est en
fait il faut mesurer à quel point
d'abord nous avons un besoin de
solidarité la face à l'urgence
pendant cette crise nous avons vu
grandir moi je les ai vus en particulier
à belfort les fils à l'aide alimentaire
qui était composée pour moitié de jeunes
étudiants dans la sixième ou septième
puissance mondiale dans notre belle
région de bourgogne franche comté
ça n'est pas acceptable ça n'est pas
supportable et de ce point de vue il ya
d'abord un programme d'urgence à mettre
en oeuvre sur les solidarité à l'égard
de la jeunesse
au programme d'urgence ça veut dire pour
nous mettre en place six mille emplois
jeunes il ya plus de quinze mille jeunes
qui sont passés au chômage pendant cette
crise ensuite il y à des aides à la
garantie des cautions pour les étudiants
parce qu'il ya des difficultés de
logement notamment dans nos villes
étudiantes
il y à une mesure à laquelle nous tenons
beaucoup qui est la gratuité des
transports pour les 18 25 ans elle a un
coût j'expliquerai plus tard dans le
débat comment j'entends la finance et ça
coûtera de l'ordre de 20 à 25 millions
d'euros
mais nous avons des ressources nouvelles
pour imaginer des gratuités nouvelle
notamment pour permettre aux jeunes de
sortir de l'assignation à résidence dans
certains quartiers merci dany thuriau
vos priorités vos mesures pour la
jeunesse
c'est une belle chose faire des
conventions citoyenne des jeunes dont
acte j'ai créé aussi des conseils
citoyenne la jeunesse mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas ce qui est
attendu
je les dis c'est une relance forte c'est
une accélération cette accélération
elle passera par des mesures beaucoup
plus concrète aujourd'hui un jeune sur
cinq est en situation de précarité en
bourgogne franche comté
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
concrètement nous proposerons un fonds
de secours équivalent du rsa pour les
plus de 25 ans 500 euros par mois pour
les accompagner vers le dispositif de
l'état 6 milliards et une bise rappelle
un jeune une solution pas les abandonner
et pas faire d'assistanat démesuré mais
les accompagner une courte durée
peut-être pour aller aussi vers le
capital jeunes pour les jeunes qui ont
un projet c'est à dire que la région
garantit race avec un dix mille euros
qui seront portées sans intérêt le temps
de remboursement qui peut être très long
jusqu'à 30 ans et a minima quand un
jeune percevra 1800 euros net par mois
c'est du concret nous doublerons si le
pass culture de l'état parce que l'accès
à la culture est primordial on n'en a
pas encore parlé
nous accompagnerons si les étudiants
dans la précarité aujourd'hui à
logements d'urgence allaient à
l'université c'est à moi et le jeune ait
mis dehors dans la rue c'est absolument
insupportable
donc la région financera davantage de
logements d'urgence et dans la durée
tant qu'elle n'aura pas une solution il
ne sera pas mis dehors
c'est aussi mettre le service national
universel partout parce qu'on a bien la
pression qu'il faut rappeler la
l'éducation et le respect des uns et des
autres voilà c'est aussi repenser aux
jeunes agriculteurs les accompagner dans
leur installation les jeunes c'est pour
nous on est partout et pour tous pour
eux parce que encore une fois il faut
être concret mais concret c'est
l'accompagnement au quotidien et c'est
pas pour l'instant ce que j'ai entendu
de mes concurrents claire rocher quelles
sont vos priorités les priorités de
votre liste pour la jeunesse en
bourgogne franche comté on pourrait
discuter du rôle de la région dans la
formation et l'enseignement supérieur
mais c'est l'état s'en est déchargée sur
la région sans beaucoup de moyens
effectivement les choses se sont
aggravées pendant la pandémie
on a vu que ce sont aussi là les
personnels qui ont tous porté qui ont dû
trouver des solutions pour que les
jeunes en particulier des classes
populaires garde le contact avec l'école
et les apprentissages
mais fondamentalement surtout le
problème c'est que les jeunes sont des
laissés pour compte dans notre société
il ya tout un pan de la jeunesse qui est
désespéré parce qu'elle n'a ni avenir ni
formation ni perspective de boulot et si
vous voulez le l'ennui c'est que
l'éducation c'est un investissement à
long terme
et ça les classes dirigeantes ne sont
pas prêtes à investir dans l'éducation
les patrons ils ont besoin de jeunes
pour avoir une main d'oeuvre à bas coût
mais ils sont pas prêts à les former à
les accompagner à les professionnaliser
et c'est la même chose à l'hôpital où je
travaille
on est prêts à acheter des robots on est
prêts à acheter des hélicoptères mais
former du personnel compétent et prendre
le temps alors que c'est l'essentiel est
que ce sont les gens qui font
fonctionner les choses ça ça passe à
côté
stéphanie modde en quoi la région
peut-elle aider ces jeunes qui souffrent
depuis un nom avec la crise sanitaire
comme on peut les aider au quotidien les
jeunes c'est notre avenir notamment dans
une région qui vieillit alors
effectivement la jeunesse c'est un
investissement
c'est pas un coût supplémentaire c'est
pas sombrer dans l'assistanat c'est les
aider concrètement c'est aussi les
écouter et moi plutôt que d'inventer des
conventions je ne sais quoi c'est aussi
déjà allé à la rencontre des
associations qui existent des
associations de jeunes qui ne demandent
qu'une chose c'est d'être écoutés
entendus pour que soient appliqués
vraiment des mesures qui soient
concrètes pour eux donc nous nous
instaurons effectivement un revenu
minimum pour les jeunes précarité quelle
que soit leur situation puisque l'état
ne le fait pas et pour l'instant une
bille communion le fait une bulle
écologistes donc les jeunes sacrifiés
pendant cette crise oui effectivement
donc c'est aussi tout ce qui tourne
autour de la formation professionnelle
que ce soit dans les lycées dans la
formation initiale dans les lycées nous
veillerons effectivement à ce que les
jeunes puissent étudier correctement ça
veut dire aussi leur sécurité c'est quoi
dans un lycée c'est avoir un lycée en
très bon état
c'est vraiment un indice et dans lequel
ils puissent étudier avec du matériel
en bon état donc c'est aussi leur
apporter des ordinateurs pour ceux qui
ont subi cette crise et qui n'étaient
pas équipés qui n'était pas outillés
pour ça c'est aussi un regard
particulier sur l'enseignement en milieu
rural parce que tous les jeunes ne
veulent pas forcément venir dans les
milieux urbains
donc c'est aussi s'assurer de la qualité
de l'enseignement qui soit
essentiellement initiale ou
professionnels partout sur l'ensemble du
territoire merci juan 12 vos priorités
pour la jeunesse de bourgogne franche
comté
je souhaite la sécurité pour nos jeunes
en bourgogne franche comté
toutes les mesures que je viens
d'entendre sont intéressantes
malheureusement toutes les mesures que
je viens d'entendre seront totalement
inefficace si les bourguignons les
francs comtois et notamment les plus
jeunes ne sont pas en sécurité de notre
région il ya une crise aujourd'hui qui
est celle de l'ensauvagement de l'ultra
violence qui mine notamment notre
jeunesse
et c'est vrai qu'on peut parler
développement économique on peut parler
de formation ont peu parlé d'insertion
on peut parler de développement
professionnel
si les gens ne sont pas en sécurité si
les bourguignons et les franc comtois ne
sont pas en sécurité
cela ne marchera pas et notre région
continuera dégringolé sur la perte
d'attractivité
donc moi je souhaite et je l'assumé
totalement que la sécurité devienne une
compétence régionale et notamment pour
notre jeunesse
parce que pendant la campagne j'ai
rencontré des centaines de jeunes des
filles des garçons des étudiants des
jeunes en apprentissage et la plupart
d'entre eux m'ont fait part non pas de
leurs sentiments
comme le dit le président de la
république mais des réalités de la
sécurité dans les gares dans les
transports dans l'espace public
aujourd'hui c'est insupportable et
notamment pour les femmes et notamment
pour les plus fragiles
donc moi je souhaite un programme pour
lutter contre l'insécurité avec les
leviers de la région ça passera
notamment par un fonds dead un fonds d
aide pour les victimes de l'insécurité
qui malheureusement sont beaucoup trop
nombreuses et notamment les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales 5
millions d'euros par an pour les
victimes de l'insécurité
ensuite un recrutement recrutement
d'agents armés pour sécuriser les gares
et les transports et pour renforcer les
effectifs de police de gendarmerie de
police municipale ensuite financer les
polices municipales donc dans les
petites communes qui n'ont pas le budget
parce que c'est indispensable et ensuite
une mesure extrêmement clair qui
mais cher ce que j'appelle l'institut
conditionnalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
candidate sortante a déversé beaucoup
d'argent dans les quartiers dits
prioritaires qui sont les quartiers les
plus dangereux
moi je souhaite responsabiliser tous les
acteurs associatifs élus locaux pour
faire en sorte qu'ils des critères en
matière de renforcement de la sécurité
en matière de renforcement des valeurs
républicaines et de la laïcité
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la sécurité doit
devenir une priorité régionale
merci thomas je me tourne vers vous je
crois vous avez une question notamment
sur l'île ces souris sur france bleu
point fr beaucoup de propositions de nos
auditeurs qui ont laissé des des pistes
des idées de travail peut-être pour vous
futur président au président de la
région bourgogne franche comté
des idées qui vous soumettent donc ce
soir
il ya par exemple marie-christine 58 ans
qui vit du côté de varois-et-chaignot
c'est en côte-d'or tout près de dijon
elle nous dit qu'elle souhaite qu'on
encourage le vivre ensemble des seniors
et des étudiants pour créer du lien
intergénérationnel regroupe un petit peu
la grande famille quoi en fait en sommes
à besançon stéphanie 51 ans explique
qu'il faudrait selon elle inciter les
lycéens à donner des cours d'internet
aux personnes âgées pourquoi pas ça peut
être une piste aussi de développement
pour des personnes âgées qui tâtonne
encore un peu avec avec le numérique
mais la question que j'ai retenu c'est
cette proposition de karine elle aussi
de besançon attention elle et elle est
très précise karine de besançon il faut
construire un lycée général et
technologique de la communauté de
communes d'où centrale d'où l'ire de
tourner vers des matériaux tout cela
bien ce qu'il faut faire vivre tout le
monde ensemble des plus jeunes aux plus
anciens
la sécurité c'est pas le rassemblement
national qui en est le garant ou l'a vu
dans d'autres villes qui sont dirigés
par le rassemblement national faut
arrêter de mentir aux gens aussi en leur
disant offert une police régionale
d'abord ça n'est pas constitutionnel
ensuite nous n'aurons pas les
financements il faut pas faire croire
cela donc oui moi je suis pour la
sécurité et la sécurité de la formation
et sécurité de l'accompagnement des
jeunes sur un parcours donc faire
travailler les plus anciens dont on a
par exemple pour idée de mettre des
médiateurs ça pourrait être des plus
sages dans la proximité des lycées en
plus des caméras ça il faut couvrir les
entrées et les accès au lycée de caméras
vidéo mais là encore ce n'est pas
l'apanage du rassemblement national pour
la question du doubs moi j'ai visité de
boli c'est qui
l'enseignement général et l'enseignement
technologique y en a un peu partout
maintenant si l'emploi supplémentaire
c'est à voir il faut qu'ils aient le
nombre d'élèves pour l'occuper
marie-guite dufay on interrogeait
beaucoup sur la jeunesse en fait on se
renvoie des on nous renvoie des réponses
sur la sécurité comment vous réagissez à
savon et notamment aux critiques qui ont
été faites à la majorité sortante voix
soit la sécurité dans les lycées comme
dans les transports ces terres les deux
compétences de la région où
effectivement nous sommes légitimes à
intervenir en matière de sécurité
nous faisons le nécessaire et dans les
lycées nous avons un plan sécurité
n'en déplaise à à monsieur platret il le
sait nous avons vos tables nous avons
voté un plan sécurité qu'ils ne trouvent
pas suffisant néanmoins nous l'avons
travailler avec les proviseurs et donc
nous avons nous n'avons absolument pas
mis de côté cette dimension ce serait
irresponsable
nous l'avons fait mais je pense qu'il y
à aussi à travailler de façon plus
culturelle sur la question de la
délinquance ya deux façons de travailler
sur la délinquance et sur l'insécurité
il ya la façon sécuritaire
il ya la façon culturelle et c'est vrai
que tout à l'heure monsieur odoul a
parlé les crédits que nous avons mis sur
les quartiers politique de la ville nous
avons mis beaucoup de crédit qu'est-ce
qui se passerait si nous n'avions pas
mis ces crédits en direction des
associations d'éducation populaire des
actions culturelles des actions des
associations qui travaillent sur
l'emploi des jeunes
il y a encore beaucoup à faire et sur
baume les dames oui dix fois oui il faut
que le lycée professionnel de
baume-les-dames s'élargissent à plus de
matières générales pour devenir un vrai
lycées d'enseignement général parce
qu'on est sur une zone en pleine
dynamique en pleine croissance et cela
nous le travaillons gilles platret
faut-il aller plus loin que ce qu'a fait
la gauche en termes de sécurité
c'est bien simple la sécurité a été son
angle mort c'est pour ça qu'il faut
l'alternance notamment
je viens là c'est pas la compétence
première les régions est ce que c'est
une compétence que les régions n'ont pas
le droit d'exercer la réponse est non la
culture non plus n'est pas une
compétence première qui souhaiteraient
aujourd'hui revenir sur les enjeux
culturels dans la région d'el compétents
de concret bien entendu une nouvelle
compétence sur la sécurité
l'exemple des lycées est flagrant je
suis maire je sais pas monsieur turnhout
curieux doit pas
je suis père de chalon dont je lui dis
je suis mère aussi il n'est pas le seul
ici mais en tout état de cause non parce
que nous on s'est partagé le pouvoir
plutôt que lorsque j'ai étendu un
système de vidéoprotection au profit des
habitants de chalon sur saône
nous avons ce nous avons vidéo de
protéger toutes les écoles notamment de
chalon et créer un système c'est 250
caméras le département de saône et loire
nous a aidés à vidéo protéger les
collèges la région obstinément et madame
du fait la première à refuser la vidéo
protection des lycées
c'est une faute aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une période d'insécurité enfants et
par conséquent est par contre je vais
jusqu'au bout madame buffet s'il me le
permettait et par conséquent demain nous
irons sur ces enjeux là c'est pas faire
du catastrophisme c'est simplement par
la sécurisation protéger la liberté de
chacun quand on aura compris que la
sécurité n'est ni droite ni gauche mais
quand l'assuré on assure la liberté
alors je pense qu'on aura communément
fait un grand pas stéphanie modde je
vous voyais faire avril ainsi volontiers
parce que pour moi j'estime entendre
parler de la genèse comme une
délinquance entendre parler de
vidéoprotection ce que demandent nos
jeunes skiff subissent actuellement leur
insécurité c'est leur insécurité de leur
avenir qui souhaite aujourd'hui c'est
pouvoir sortir de nouveau c'est pouvoir
refaire du sport refaire des activités
culturelles sportives
voilà donc c'est ça vraiment intéressant
l'intérêt donc c'est aussi remettre de
l'humain parce que effectivement les
services publics ont été mis à mal
encore une fois dans les lycées nous
intervenons sur le bâtiment mais pas sur
le personnel pas tout sur les personnels
donc c'est remettre aussi de l'humain
dans nos lycées c'est permettre
effectivement aux jeunes des quartiers
défavorisés qui sont souvent stigmatisés
d'avoir la même chose que les autres de
même que des jeunes en milieu rural on
voit quelle différence
effectivement la région a des atouts et
la nécessité de donner la même chance à
l'ensemble des jeunes là où ils habitent
et pour finir sur les lycées il ya aussi
un besoin autour de sens parce qu'alice
a senti un énorme lycée 2500 élèves je
pense qu'effectivement il faut des
lycées aussi à puce à taille humaine et
donc se pose aussi la réflexion et nous
nous proposons la réflexion autour de la
construction d'un nouveau lycée vers
sens julien houle est ce que vous voyez
la jeunesse seulement comme la
délinquance j'aimerais répondre à madame
buffet sur les compétences de la région
la santé initialement n'était pas une
compétence régionale ça l'est devenu
avec la crise sanitaire et c'est une
bonne chose
la région a notamment passé des
commandes de masques la région a investi
pour équiper l'hôpital public
millions d'euros la région a même acheté
une machine à masquer est-ce que ça
choque quelqu'un que accents titre
devenue une compétence non aujourd'hui
la sécurité des biens et des personnes
est une priorité une impérieuse priorité
est encore une fois aucune collectivité
ne peut s'en exonérer
alors moi je suis assez stupéfait de
voir que certaines personnes certains
responsables politiques considèrent que
la sécurité de nos concitoyens ne les
regarde pas moi la sécurité voyez c'est
ce dont on parle en priorité parce que
clairement aujourd'hui dans l'espace
public que ce soit dans les transports
dans les gares que ce soit même en pour
aller au travail
aujourd'hui il ya une insécurité qui est
galopante et sur les crédits qui ont été
réellement sur les crédits qui ont été
affectés à la politique de la ville
parce que c'est important
madame du fait nous dit finalement qu'il
faut mettre plus d'argent plus d'argent
pour éteindre l'incendié
alors que les quartiers aujourd'hui de
la région bourgogne franche comté qui
ont reçu le plus d'argent public c'est à
dire sur les cinq années un demi
milliard d'euros si on prend les cinq
quartiers les plus dangereux qui sont
notamment comme le quartier de ma ville
de sens des chaillots où des émeutes
urbaines ont eu lieu il ya deux jours
sont des quartiers les plus riches
moi je souhaite responsabilités et
arrêter tout simplement de verser de
l'argent pour alimenter la délinquance
ond vient on revient s'il vous plaît aux
compétences premières de la région les
régions qui ont été créés pour devenir
les chefs de file de l'action économique
alors on s'est tous nos entreprises ont
énormément souffert dans tous les
secteurs d'activité comment la région
peut-elle les aider à se relever comment
finalement on relance la machine
gilles platret vous commencez s'il vous
plaît oui c'est un enjeu énorme et vous
avez raison de rappeler que la région
est chef de file sauf que là aussi on
peut être frappé d'un constat finalement
d'une dune sous d'affectation des
crédits régionaux en direction du
développement économique nous nous
estimons que pour être à peu près au
niveau des régions voisines qui sont des
régions qui sont très attractives
ne l'oublions jamais le bassin parisien
au val rhône alpes la suisse grand s et
l'allemagne qui est juste à nos portes
il faut qu'on mette le paquet sur le
développement économique ça veut dire en
gros chaque année nous estimons le
besoin supplémentaire de financement à
40 millions d'euros qui iront au
développement et à l'accompagnement des
entreprises
une région qui aident les entreprises
c'est celle qui est de l'emploi
ça n'a de sens que si elle crée de la
richesse c'est bien la fonction première
des entreprises projet
oubliez donc pour les aider il faut déjà
évité de matraques et tout le monde avec
les impôts je note que cette région avec
la présidente sortante a augmenté
énormément les impôts notamment sur les
cartes grises au début du mandat aux
dépens des francs comtois nous
reviendrons sur un taux antérieur nous
simplifieront également les règlements
d'intervention pour les entreprises je
le retrouve partout des chefs
d'entreprise qui n'en peuvent plus des
dossiers administratifs trop lourd de la
région
je sens là aussi que voulait mater
reviendrait vers moi pour que la parole
circule bien alors je prends la parole
sur l'économie et l'aide aux entreprises
la création d'emplois cette affaire je
joue dans l'industrie pour la bourgogne
franche comté c'est la première région
industrielle du pays et doit être notre
fierté à tous et à tout parce que
l'industrie
c'est le coeur de métier là où se font
les compétences se fait la fierté des
populations dans notre région et c'est
aussi le coeur de l'innovation
le problème on le voit bien aujourd'hui
dans une économie totalement mondialisé
on l'a vu avec la crise et de l'épidémie
de kovy de l'an dernier lorsque nous
sommes clients à l'échelle de la
mondialisation nous sommes d'abord
captifs
on l'a vu avec les masses on l'a vu avec
les respirateurs artificiels l'enjeu
essentiel aujourd'hui c'est d'être
capable de réarmer notre production
locale réarmer notre production locale
ont fait quelques propositions
d'abord participé en mettant 100
millions d'euros sur la base sur la
table je dis bien 100 millions d'euros
sur la table et trouver ou pour
participer
je vais y répondre juste un instant je
poursuis 100 millions d'euros sur la
table pour participer au rachat de la
partie j steam c'est à dire la partie
vapeur de general electric qui avait été
abandonné par emmanuel macron et
françois le hollande en 2014 2015
ça c'est un enjeu essentiel pour la
souveraineté énergétique et industriel
du pays il ya plus de dix mille emplois
dans la filière nucléaire par exemple
dans notre région
par ailleurs je pense qu'il est
essentiel de soutenir en particulier de
manière prioriser les filières
structurant de l'économie de production
l'énergie les transports
l'agroalimentaire l'horlogerie la
foresterie pour relocaliser là aussi on
voit par exemple que dans le morvan
quête à une région particulièrement
boisé comme chacun sait la filière du
bois aujourd'hui pour
à faire des coupes rases a envoyé le
bois en chine la transformation se fait
en chine
eon rae apporte ensuite c'est bien il
est essentiel de plus la formation
professionnelle jusqu'à la mise en
oeuvre de l'activité industrielle elle
même que nous ayons les compétences sur
le territoire pour faire y compris
l'industrie manufacturière et je
poursuis parce que je n'ai pas pu
reprendre la parole dans le point
précédent très vite c'est en fait de sa
forme mais je m'en doute par ailleurs je
pense qu'il ya un point essentiel c'est
d'encourager la démondialisation de
notre économie
alors c'est un thème que vous savez
chers au coeur d'arnaud montebourg et
auxquels je suis moi aussi très attaché
il faut que la région crée un vrai label
fabriqué en bourgogne franche comté sur
lequel on fait pas une opération de com
sur lequel on crée une vraie filière de
distribution sur lesquels on se sent
guère pratiquement de façon à ce que
nous ayons de l'emploi pour la jeunesse
mer et ça me semble beaucoup plus
important pour la jeunesse d'avoir de
l'emploi plutôt qu'un discours figé sur
les insécurités donc nous a parlé mais
je suis un cocker rocher comment on
choisit des entreprises dans lesquelles
on met de l'argent selon quels critères
on va écouter en tout cas visiblement
les general electric alstom peugeot etc
ils ont déjà leur entrée au niveau
étatique pour recevoir toutes les
subventions mais la région tient quand
même à montrer qu'elle participe à
l'effort et à en remettre un peu ça lui
sert à partager le gâteau finalement à
partager le gâteau entre ces grandes
entreprises qui ont déjà des milliards
et on leur en redonne encore un petit
peu avec la pandémie ça a été des
records de faire la nationalisation
madame en jeu vous allez me laisser
terminer
c'est à ça que sert le conseil régional
c'est à partager le gâteau de l'argent
public entre différentes couches de la
bourgeoisie ce que je dénonce mais
surtout à quoi il va servir cet argent
il sauvera aucun emploi il ya bien
longtemps que les entreprises
n'investissent plus la bourgeoisie elle
elle était déjà en crise avant le début
de la pandémie et le problème actuel
c'est que ces grands groupes ils
spéculent avec tout l'argent qu'on leur
donne et on peut leur en donner tenter
plus c'est le serpent qui se mord la
queue cet argent ira en bourse parce que
c'est ce qui rapporte donc moi je pense
que c'est presque un leurre c'est
reculer pour mieux sauter parce que ça
prépare encore un crash boursier
encore plus important qu'est ce que vous
proposez moi je pense que les
travailleurs qui ont prouvé qu'il
faisait tout fonctionné pendant cette
pandémie et bien au delà ont prouvé
qu'ils pouvaient le faire de façon
complètement responsable bien plus que
cette classe dirigeante qui nous emmène
vers des crises et je pense que c'est à
eux de diriger la société et a certes ça
ne se fera pas par une élection j'ai
régionales mais on peut l'affirmer et le
préparer et c'est à ça que sert malice
d'inertie claire rocher denis thuriau
vos priorités en matière économique s'il
vous plaît la matière économique c'est
ça la vraie sécurité la sécurité d'avoir
un emploi de le garder de pouvoir se
former par une formation continue de se
reconvertir de se reclasser
ça c'est de la vraie sécurité qui est de
la compétence de la région et nous
sommes évidemment fortement dans
l'accompagnement de cela d'ailleurs dès
que je serai élu si on me fait confiance
ils ont fait confiance à mon équipe je
réunir et l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques l'ensemble y compris de
l'université qui n'est pas du tout
associé qui n'a pas dit à l'heure
actuelle manque la région pour définir
des pôles d'excellence
là on en a plein sur la région mais pôle
d'excellence à identifier les besoins
des territoires c'est plus la région qui
imposera ses les territoires qui ont
demandé qu'ils iront mettre en évidence
les richesses qu'ils ont et les besoins
de formation parce qu'effectivement
beaucoup d'entreprises aussi qui
arrivent pas recruter vise à aider les
pme les tpe des artisans les
agriculteurs
est ce que comme notre vous souhaitez
que la région investissent dans des
entreprises en difficulté
écoutez quand y'a moyen et si vous
faites allusion à une société
dimanche je suis allée la visite et je
sais qu'au plus haut niveau de l'état on
s'en inquiète il faut évidemment
privilégier l'investissement privé quand
on peut trouver si maintenant c'est pour
sauver 300 emplois dans une industrie
qui se reconvertit et c'est le cas du
secteur automobile qui est très impacté
par ce qu'on va parler de transition
écologique mais en partie à cause de la
transition écologique mais c'est aussi
un progrès quelque part il faut
davantage prendre le temps d'accompagner
donc oui si la région doit mettre la
main à la poche pour sauver 300 emplois
elle le fera en s'assurant de la
pérennité par ailleurs vous parlez
former des jeunes
vous parlez des bf aluminium cette
fonderie en difficulté dans le haut-jura
varig et du fer vous
êtes allez vous aussi sur le terrain
pourquoi vous avez été auprès de ses
salariés là pourquoi aider cette
entreprise-là particulièrement parce que
la perspective qu'il n'y ait pas de
reprise sur cette fonderie à saint
claude
c'est la perspective de la mort d'un
territoire
c'est une perspective dramatique pour
tous les hommes et les femmes qui
travaillent dans cette entreprise
donc à partir du moment où il ya des
repreneurs qui ont été sur le coup et
que petit à petit les perspectives de
reprise se sont effondrés mais consent
et on le sait que cette entreprise peut
être une fonderie du futur parce qu'il y
a des machines qui sont extrêmement
performante parce qu'il y à une matière
grise à l'intérieur de cette entreprise
importante parce qu'il ya des savoir
faire qui sont uniques c'est un peu
comme un general electric à belfort des
savoirs qui son savoir faire qui sont
uniques et bien on ne peut pas baisser
les bras
et donc j'ai proposé une solution je ne
sais pas si nous pourrons aller jusqu'au
bout mais si nous ne pouvons pas aller
jusqu'au bout c'est la liquidation de
l'entreprise et cette solution c'est
public privé la région investit dans le
capital et va chercher des investisseurs
pour reprendre alors puisque j'ai la
parole dire très rapidement que sur le
plan économique c'est tous les feux
qu'il faut pousser pour aider les
entreprises au démarrage quand elles se
développent quand elles vont mal
l'industrie bien sûr bastien photo au
coeur mais y'a pas que l'industrie ya
aussi toute l'économie tour de proximité
sur les territoires les commerces
l'artisanat pour lesquelles nous avons
bâti dans cette région une alliance avec
tous les territoires pour mettre en
place des mesures les protégeant pendant
la crise et leur permettant aujourd'hui
de rebondir je suis peut-être trop
longue
j'aurai encore beaucoup à dire julien
houle vos priorités en matière
économique
s'il vous plaît déjà le constat est
quand même très alarmant le constat
aujourd'hui nous le subissons dans la
région ces deux cent quarante cinq mille
chômeurs ces quatre cent mille pauvre et
c'est des plans sociaux qui se succèdent
les uns après les autres et ses plans
sociaux sont le résultat de quoi pas de
la crise du coc vide non des politiques
de rentabilité qui ont été menées du
système économique dans lequel nous
sommes qui celui de
macron monsieur macron qui encore une
fois était soutenu par le madame du fait
parce que madame du fait aujourd'hui a
beau jeu de pleurer sur le lait renversé
de faire un peu de volontarisme avec mpf
mais clairement general electric c'est
l'oeuvre de monsieur macron general
electric c'est la région n'a rien fait
ou si vous êtes président le saas est
votre constat si vous êtes président
qu'est ce que vous proposez ce que par
exemple vous investissez dans les
entreprises en difficulté le constat il
est très important puisqu'il permet de
rectifier et moi je souhaite notamment
la création d'un fonds souverain
régional de 100 millions d'euros pour
intervenir dans les entreprises qui
seraient menacées de plans de
licenciements pour intervenir aussi pour
reconstruire certaines entreprises pour
investir dans les filières d'avenir
ce fonds souverain régionale permettrait
de sauver mbf permettrait de sauver
general electric moi ce que je constate
c'est ce que je déplore c'est que la
région pendant cinq ans n'a rien fait
même du fait se réveillent maintenant en
période électorale
rien n'a été fait depuis rien n'a été
fait depuis le début est fait qu alain
kirouac et assez ce qui est assez
excusez moi même du fait mais on peut
redouter au regard de ce qui a été fait
depuis des mois et de votre passivité de
votre extrême passivité sur tous les
dossiers parce qu'on pourrait parler de
jacob delafon on peut parler d skype
on peut parler naito cheese donc moi ce
que je souhaite c'est que la région
devienne un bouclier social pour que la
bourgogne franche comté ne se transforme
pas en désert industriel
il en va de l'attractivité évidemment de
notre région de nos territoires ayant va
aussi des futurs emplois de nos jeunes
quoi il retournait la parole dit
stéphanie modde demande la parole de
pierre maman allez-y merci donc oui
effectivement il faut aider les
entreprises en difficulté il fallait idf
par contre il faut vraiment à partir de
maintenant vraiment voir que les aides
qui sont donnés octroyés à des
entreprises soit donne à des entreprises
dont le siège social n'est pas à
l'étranger dont les fonds
d'investissement ne vont pas servir une
partie qui n'a rien à voir avec la
france et qui donc de toutes façons
c'est aider des entreprises qui peuvent
délocaliser sur lequel on n'a pas de
possibilité d'agir
donc c'est aussi permettre aux
entreprises qui sont reprises de l'être
aussi en coopérative en sic parce que ça
c'est intéressant c'est aussi permettre
bien évidemment de relocaliser nos
trains d'une autre en outre industrie en
s'appuyant sur les filières d'avenir en
lien avec la transition écologique
énergétique et répartir aussi de
l'ensemble des emplois sur l'ensemble du
territoire s'était dit aussi
c'est tous ce qui est servi commerce de
proximité création pire lieu en réalité
aussi pour l'emploi local
c'est aussi tout ce qui est autour de
son guidon mais j'ai pas parlé du
programme économique encore prête pour
rapidement c'est vraiment aussi ne pas
faut concentrer l'emploi sur une partie
du territoire
c'est le maître sur l'ensemble du
territoire pour que chacun puisse vivre
et travailler là où le souhaitent
et encore une fois la transition
écologique et les chefs d'entreprise que
nous rencontrons notamment dans
l'industrie du disque effectivement
c'est une chance pour notre région
stéphanie modde on disait non à la
question qu'on nous pose et dans
l'oreillette ans s'était pas par rapport
à ce que vous disiez juste vous avez la
parole je vais vouloir donner et on va
faire un tour
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire oui ou
non faut-il continuer à aider à
subventionner l'aéroport de dole quelle
infrastructure importante et qui
concerne aussi le des le les questions
économiques
moi je pense qu'il faut surtout aider
toutes les structures de tourisme de
tourisme durable voilà oui oxala europe
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas nous les gens
qui souhaitent prendre l'avion à dole
pourront prendre l'avion mais le
prendrons ouvrez prix d'un billet
d'avion donc non indique non en tout cas
à l'aide aux low cost ça c'est évident
parce que le tourisme local ça c'est une
vraie chance et le tourisme durable nous
allons aider les entreprises
les personnes qui souhaitent
effectivement créer de l'activité dans
ce secteur d'activité et ne pas croire
que comme à comme avant nous aurons un
tourisme international qui va revenir en
masse parce que de toute façon pour les
années qui viennent ce n'est pas
possible et ce n'est pas souhaitable
forcément pour la planète
la boe franche-comté est la seule région
en france qui n'a pas un aéroport forme
arquée et aéroports c'est de l'économie
c'est du tourisme dokoui je considère
que c'est complètement anormal que la
région ne soit pas impliqué dans le
fonctionnement de l'aéroport que je suis
allé visiter et pour moi je souhaiterais
l'accompagner pour qu'il se développe et
qui le bénéficie aux flux économiques et
touristiques
l'accompagnement l'aéroport doit devenir
un aéroport régional c'est une
aberration qui ne soit pas déjà on peut
pas laisser le département du jura qui
très courageusement alors que seuls 10 %
des passagers sont jurassien paye la
quasi totalité des investissements être
seul donc demain l'aéroport qui est un
noeud en jeu
un objet de développement y compris pour
nos habitants mais également pour le
tourisme international sera un aéroport
régional geignarde au président de
région je soutiendrai massivement cet
atout formidable pour notre région
c'est inadmissible que ce trésor parce
que l'aéroport est un trésor n'est pas
été valorisé accompagné soutenu par la
région socialistes c'est clairement des
emplois des investissements et aussi
développement du tourisme et donc le
tourisme c'est quoi des emplois non
délocalisables pour notre région
marie-guite dufay notre réponse dire que
nous n'avons pas soutenu l'aéroport de
dole tavaux et et il faut puisque nous
soutenons le fonctionnement de la plate
forme et que nous avons même doubler ce
fonctionnement par solidarité
précisément avec le département du jura
par contre par contre effectivement nous
n'avons pas pris le pilotage de cet
aéroport
aujourd'hui il y a un différend une
discussion entre départements du jura et
nous sur le modèle je ne crois pas au
modèle tel qu'il est aujourd'hui avec
des touristes qui partent de cet
aéroport pour aller dépenser leur
pouvoir d'achat au maroc maroc en
tunisie au portugal 1 il faut faire
venir des touristes du nord qui viennent
dépenser leur pouvoir d'achat dans notre
région dans nos montagnes dans nos
vignobles ça on le dit depuis des années
j'ai vu ça j'ai toujours dit la même
chose toujours ses enfants l'ont
rapidement
oui ben je pense que il faut repenser
modèle économique de cet aéroport et
puis le mettre aussi dans une
perspective inter régionales parce que
la logique petits fanions nous aussi on
veut notre aéroport international
il ya paris avec deux aéroports lyon
saint-exupéry et bâle mulhouse
la question doit se poser en termes de
réseau les habitants de l'yonne près de
sens ont de toute façon plus intérêt à
l'est les aéroports de paris que de se
rendre sur celui de dole tavaux de
réfléchissons autrement que de façon
étriqué comme ça dans la tête
allez on avance dans le débat on parlait
d'aéroport parler d'environnement
présent notre région a vécu ces
dernières années plusieurs épisodes de
sécheresse très important les études le
disent nous aurons dans une trentaine
d'années le climat de la côte d'azur et
dans au siècle prochain celui de la
grèce
ce qu'on voudrait savoir c'est comment
les uns les autres vous si vous arrivez
à la présidence du conseil régional vous
entendez adapter notre région au
réchauffement climatique julien au
double vous avez la parole
l'environnement déjà c'est notre
quotidien à tous c'est évidemment notre
cadre de vie c'est notre économie
puisque c'est les factures que nous
payons c'est notre électricité
c'est la biodiversité c'est tout ça
c'est pas de l'idéologie
moi je suis pour une écologie heureuse
une écologie positive pas une écologie
est la triste robe c'est à dire
notamment une écologie qui veut taxer
encore plus avec cette écotaxe qui est
une aberration qui ne fera pas chuter la
pollution mais en tout cas qui fera
chuter le nombre d'emplois dans notre
région et moi je suis pour une écologie
aussi qui est pragmatique qui est lucide
c'est à dire pas le déploiement massif
des éoliennes qui est la marotte et
malheureusement l'obsession de la
candidate sortante 403 éoliennes qui
infestent nos terroirs en bourgogne
franche-comté marie-guite dufay veut
continuer dans cette obsession qui
encore une fois saccagent la
biodiversité pour plong l'attractivité
économique puisque évidemment on veut
bien aller à vézelay on veut bien aller
arc-et-senans on veut bien aller à voir
le magnifique patrimoine des châteaux
mais on n'a pas envie de voir des
éoliennes
donc moi ce que je souhaite c'est déjà
posé la question bourguignon aux francs
comtois un grand référendum sur la
politique environnementale et ensuite
clairement moratoire sur l'implantation
d'éoliennes projet de démantèlement qui
sont tout à fait possibles avec des
recours et je soutiendrai toutes les
associations de défense de la nature
pardon vous allez faire pour les
démonter vous avez pas droit bien sûr
qu'on peut avec des recours vous savez
que ça existe dans d'autres départements
les collectivités qui soutiennent des
associations qui soutiennent des
associations rigole julien au docteur se
tramait ce qu'elle sait a su hallucinant
c'est qu'en fait on ne regarde pas ce
qui se passe en dehors des frontières la
bourgogne franche comté
vous avez des associations qui ont été
soutenues qui ont permis notamment de
démonter certaines éoliennes que ce soit
pour des nuisances sanitaires pour une
mise en scène sonore des nuisances
environnementales
donc c'est tout à fait possible encore
une fois c'est une question de volonté
et ensuite l'investissement sur les
énergies
réellement renouvelables c'est à dire
que nous avons l'hydroélectricité nous
avons l'hydrogène
nous avons la filière bois tout cela
c'est évidemment vertueux possible et
c'est de l'emploi encore pantech d'un
iturrioz sur les éoliennes c'est dément
le rassemblement national avec qui
j'avais pas encore eu l'honneur de
débattre puisque pas vu monsieur ou
double dans les cinq débats précédents
fait beaucoup de vent moi je parlerais
si vous dès qu'on parle des olé mêlée je
suis désolé l'environnement la
transition écologique la transition
énergétique c'est pas que les éoliennes
et donc moi je ne souhaite pas réduire
le débat à ce tag à la biodiversité il
ya l'eau je souhaite en faire une grande
cause régionale parce que l'eau de
l'hiver ça doit être clos de l'été et
mettre en harmonie les dispositifs
législatifs pour la rétention d'eau
notamment pour les maraîchers des
agriculteurs excitant c'est que c'est un
enjeu fort évidemment accompagné le
logement dans la transition énergétique
sont les intercommunalités qui le font
principalement mais la région doit être
là dessus aussi
on veut tous un mix énergétique vous
savez être tous contre quelque chose où
tout pour quelque chose ça n'a plus de
sens aujourd'hui l'éolien
je pense qu'il ne faut pas le mettre à
la porte si je puis dire d'abord faut
rappeler je rappelle à monsieur double
qui a du mal à avoir révisé que ça
relève de l'état c'est l'état qui décide
c'est pas les présidents de région par
contre-coup de la région qui finance
mais eux n'ont rien c'est la région de
la légende huriaux en vol voilà phase i
will i am legend en vol par thurien
suffisamment la région qui fait
suffisamment monsieur de signer je vais
appeler à respecter l'autre la région
s'ils veulent être président de région
ça serait peut-être bien vous appreniez
certains disent inquiets dont la jolie
future ue forme de vendée voilà c'est
bon m'autorise à parler
allez merci beaucoup je voulais dire que
il ya par exemple des zones où ça ne
gène pas en bordure d'autoroute où il
faut pas que ça défile paysanne il faut
pas que ça gêne des habitants mais ça
fait partie de sa vie de nos ancêtres
utiliser le vent depuis très longtemps
pour l'énergie si le pétrole n'est pas
d'accord non pas du tout enfin je suis
pas d'accord avec ce que je viens
d'entendre je suis enfin on est le
référendum sur l'éolien il est dit il
est déjà fait je vous renvoie à l'étude
que vient de sortir opinionway pour la
bourgogne et franche comté
vous avez 70 à 80% des habitants qui se
prononce contre l'éolien c'est fini
c'est fini l'éolien et donc qu'elle nous
fait à la pl nous on a fermé les
centrales carrément vous en avez droit
on a fait alliance
oui avec le mouvement écologiste
indépendant qui est un mouvement
d'antoine waechter anti-éoliens pro
nucléaire est volontiers chasseurs donc
je vais vous dire clairement on a une
énergie quelle énergie la pub décarbonés
qu'ils soient qui s'appelle le
claire on la soutient tant qu'on
construit des centrales mais franchement
t on n'a pas besoin mais on est en
autonomie pourquoi voulez-vous de
nouvelles centrales
il suffit d'entretenir les centrales qui
existent en france car il va enfin vivre
le temps des rennais mais on l'aimé on
les entretient tout simplement
mais on se pose des problèmes lors qu'on
n'a pas vous savez que l'énergie
éolienne qui s'était produit par les
éoliennes ont l'ex porte aujourd'hui
elle est en plus de notre propre
production nationale donc on arrête de
fantasmer autour de l'éolien c'est une
mauvaise énergie
elle porte atteinte à la biodiversité
elle détruit le paysage et le paysage
c'est d'abord le sens même de notre
environnement
donc oui aux énergies décarbonées type
la méthanisation résonner la petite
hydroélectricité l'hydrogène quand sa
production est décarbonée sans souci là
dessus mais arrêtons le fantasme de
l'éolien c'est terminé stéphanie volle
oui moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
être sérieux dans ce débat et que le
mandat qui a ri c'est le mandat du
climat donc déjà la meilleure énergie
c'est celle qu'on ne dépense pas c'est
pourquoi déjà la priorité absolue c'est
un grand plan de rénovation thermique
vraiment très efficace pour lutter
contre les gaz à effet de serre lutter
aussi contre la précarité énergétique
qui gagne de plus en plus de nos
concitoyens dans notre région et c'est
très bon pour l'emploi local
après se pose effectivement le mix
énergétique dans lequel l'éolien à sa
place l'éolien effectivement il faut
implanter pas n'importe où c'est pas des
fonds d'investissement qui doit être à
la manoeuvre
mais effectivement beaucoup plus de
citoyens deux collectivités locales et
territoriales qui doit son nom
n'apparaît pas forcément c'est ça qui
sont démentes et celles qui sont
démentes et c'est bien pour ça que je
suis bien pour ça que je ne veux pas
qu'on pense y ont effectué leurs enjeux
de la société sont les citoyens
il ya de l'argent qui a été épargné la
proposons aux citoyens d'investir dans
une dans une énergie locale non
délocalisables pour le coup qui ne soit
pas le nucléaire le nucléaire
actuellement
effectivement les centrales sont en fin
de vie il ya de nombreux centres à cons
de proust sérieux problèmes de
fonctionnement
le p r dont on nous vante les mérites
c'était 3 milliards d'euros démarrage
mais dans l'ain à 20 milliards d'euros
on nous dit qu'on va en construire six
autres c'est n'importe quoi avec cet
argent faisons autre chose faisons autre
chose notamment aussi donc nous pour les
transports en commun encore une fois
parce que les ter c'est notre compétence
et que par ce biais là nous avons aussi
des économies à faire en termes de gaz à
effet de serre et c'est aussi et des
économies pour les voyages pour lier
pour notamment les personnes pour le
transport du quotidien qui viennent
travailler qui viennent faire leurs
études de leur proposer des tarifs
attractifs et puisse effectivement tout
ce qui tourne autour de la biodiversité
et ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure la
forêt enjeu majeur un tiers de notre
territoire une forêt en très mauvais
état
il faut donc investir vraiment sur la
biodiversité dans notre région pour
pouvoir effectivement sauvegarder notre
climat et notre planète et en même temps
les bruines franche-comté jeu mais tend
vers un mano gagne on comprend ce même
question je crois que la wii sur france
bleu point fr les auditeurs nous ont
fait part de leur envie d'avoir des des
trains mieux qu'à danser
c'est le cas notamment de pascal 55 ans
du doubs qui nous dit que voilà il
faudrait valoriser les transports en
commun mieux qu'à danser les trains et
elle ajoute il faudrait faire comme en
suisse
que pensez-vous de marie galante et
marie-guite dufay je vous laisse
répondre à cette question et puis aux
éoliennes à la discussion sur les
éoliennes convient de revenir sur les
éoliennes
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire pas
n'importe où pas n'importe comment
mais arrêtons de passionnés ce débat ce
n'est absolument pas rationnel je veux
pas trop en dire de plus parce que je
suis parfaitement en phase avec ce qui
vient d'être dit ça serait redondant les
studios le sujet sur le sujet du régime
vous avez en règle qui n'en avec
stéphanie modde d'accord non mais son
but le réchauffement climatique puisque
c'est le sujet là vous nous interroger
je veux quand même dire que la région
depuis deux ans à travailler avec tous
les territoires toutes les entreprises
toutes les associations
une démarche pour embarquer tout le
monde sur justement non pas l'adaptation
au changement climatique
mais comment pousser une révolution dans
ce domaine dans toutes nos politiques
nous avons adopté une démarche elle a
été rejetée par l'ensemble de mon
opposition pourquoi parce que j'avais
mis comme principe numéro un le zéro
artificialisation net des sols pour
arrêter le développement anarchique des
zones commerciales pour reconquérir les
bords cette bourse entre avec leur
commerce pour reconquérir les terres
agricole sa a été rejetée nous allons
continuer parce que vous nous interroger
sur comment on va faire qu'à un cap qui
a été donnée là pour massifier tout ce
qu'il faut massifier les économies
d'énergie les énergies renouvelables
plus de diesel dans l'est dans les
trains effectivement dès des circuits
courts dans l'alimentation massifier
massifier mais pour cela il faut
convaincre il faut embarquer tout le
monde et c'est pour cela que nous avons
bâti un socle déjà de réglementation et
de préconisations qui fait que
maintenant on peut construire la maison
excuse moi mais si vous n'étiez pas dans
une position denis pouliot est ce que
vous auriez été d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire marie-guite dufay rixe qui
a été fait par la partie 6e mais moi
j'ai pas être d'accord ou pas expliqué
c'est parce que je suis pas encore une
fois sortant et je compte proposer
d'autres choses sur les petites lignes
chouette y revenir c'est important de
miser transports a annoncé la relance
des petites lignes et donc elle est
engagée évidemment qu'on va y souscrire
je prends la lignée des hirondelles que
je suis allé voir aussi je pense que ça
fait partie de la proximité
la démocratie c'est la proximité elle a
un coût mais de façon le transport coûte
il faut juste voir mais je pense à une
bonne suggestion de votre auditeurs le
bon cadencement les bons horaires ça ça
va ce travail et que les élus locaux qui
connaissent bien leur territoire et je
suis convaincu que si on trouve d'autres
horaires ont fait monter plus de monde
dans le train et donc ce coup on peuvent
plus facilement le supporter a six
enfants dont vous ne vous êtes pas
exprimé sur ce thème encore mais
j'attendais que vous me donnez la base
est maintenant wiimakes ce que j'ai
entendu m'inquiète beaucoup quand jean
thomé su platret odoul sur la jeunesse
et nous parle sécurité tous les deux et
quand on leur parle réchauffement
climatique ils nous disent non aux
éoliennes
avec ça on va avancer messieurs c'est
certain ce énième alors je veux dire non
mais je compte aller jusqu'au bout de
mon propos je suis sûr vous aurez
l'occasion de répondre mais je veux dire
une chose simple
d'abord il faut qu'on concentre nos
moyens nos crédits et notre énergie là
où c'est le plus efficace
alors parlons des trois sujets
importants matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
le premier c'est la dé mondialisation
des échanges de lady et la question du
transport de marchandises
c'est 20 % des gaz à effet de serre dans
le pays c'est pour ça que nous proposons
au temps des cerises une éco taxe
progressive monsieur odoul avec une
franchise de 300 km c'est à discuter
avec l'état pour précisément protéger ta
si ça vous fait rien monsieur platret je
vais jusqu'au bout
boîte et ensuite vous pourrez répondre
alors c'est je compte terminer mon
propos monsieur platret vraiment créé
deux flics ce mot là nous est
particulièrement s'il vous plaît si vous
parlez en même temps les uns que les
autres
personne ne comprend rien mais en
l'espèce monsieur place les droits
devant la presse ben oui mais parce que
monsieur platret vous ne voulez pas
écouter on vous connaît à droite vous ne
voulez pas aimer arrêts alors je vais
aller je vais être un événement que
j'irai jusqu'au bout de ma bien sûr
c'est d'éveiller pourquoi allons au
coeur du sujet à 36 à 6 à 39
nous avons trois grandes artères où
passent l'essentiel du traspy du trafic
européen de poids lourds qui va du
portugal jusqu'en lituanie le sujet
numéro un j'ai pris là 36 encore ce
matin faites l'exercice un véhicule sur
deux
c'est un poids lourd et 9 poids lourd
sur 10 sont des poids lourds qui
viennent de pologne de slovénie de
l'ensemble du continent européen
or aujourd'hui que se passe-t-il nous
avons tous les inconvénients en termes
de sécurité routière et en termes de
pollution et nous novembre et tirons
aucun avantage et je propose de mettre
en place cette écotaxe avec une
franchise de 300 km pour protéger
l'économie l'économie locale monsieur
odoul est par ailleurs ça permet
d'obtenir 60 à 80 millions d'euros de
recettes nouvelles qui consiste pour
l'essentiel à taxer le transport
européens qui utilisent nos
infrastructures
alors évidemment je n'ai plus développé
que ce poids là monsieur cheuvreux je
suis sûr que vous allez me laisser
encore non non oui mais rapidement et
bien entendu par ailleurs il y à l'enjeu
sur le transport des personnes l'habitat
ensuite 30% des gaz à effet de serre
alors là je prends une position sur un
sujet très important mais il
s'effondrait sur ce point sinon je vous
laisse pas finir c'est fondamental c'est
le maintien du service public
ferroviaire pour pouvoir en améliorer la
qualité
il ya un enjeu d'égalité territoriales
aujourd'hui dans notre région merci
bastien photo claire rocher sur cette
thématique sur les transports déjà pour
répondre à votre dit rice effectivement
les besoins dans ce domaine
ils sont légion et les besoins non
satisfaits mais c'est pas compliqué de
les recenser et de mettre les moyens
qu'il faut simplement entre ses besoins
non satisfaits
les millions de chômeurs qui pourraient
faire le travail eh bien il ya une
classe sociale qui possède les capitaux
et les moyens de produire et qui ne veut
les faire fonctionner que quand ça lui
rapporte du profit c'est à ce barrage
quand se heurtent et c'est celui là
qu'il faudra surmonter maintenant sur le
climat et sur l'environnement
c'est un problème grave moi je suis
désolé de voir les glaciers du pôle nord
fondre comme neige au soleil
mais ça réclame bien d'autres solutions
que d'en parler avec des petites
solutions réformiste un peu ridicule
c'est un problème qui se pose à
l'échelle de l'humanité et ma liste elle
permet justement de le poser à ce niveau
là parce que si vous voulez seules les
classes non possédantes celles qui n'ont
aucun intérêt justement dans cette loi
du profit qui n'ont rien à perdre a
changé la façon dont cette société
fonctionne pourront la faire fonctionner
dans le sens de l'intérêt général et en
préservant la planète
merci denis curio comment on améliore
les trains du nocturne où il a même
failli aussi une plâtrée ces plâtres et
pardonnez moi comment on améliore le ter
pour ce soit plus flatteurs pour lui que
pour moi comment la bien voilà on
accepte la crise a fabriqué par monsieur
mon cher collègue maire alors si on y
arrive sur la question des ter je pense
que on a trop laissé faire
vous avez des présidents de région qui
se sont battus qui ont fait le bras de
fer avec la sncf
nous on a dit amen à tout on n'a pas été
cette force qui étaient décidés à
protéger les usagers et aujourd'hui on
en paye le prix avec une dégradation de
service
alors on essaye de bricoler des accord
de dernière minute notamment pour les
pauvres navetteurs du nord de l'yonne
qui font qu'ils voyagent dans des
conditions apocalyptiques tous les jours
il fallait ouvrir à la concurrence il
paye bien entendu qu'il fallait la
tester ça c'était la grande faute cette
majorité sortante
la loi nous donnait la possibilité voilà
ça normalement l'extrême gauche
effectivement réagi au moment où je
parle de d'ouverture la concurrence vous
réagissez quand c'est normal mais là les
alizés et heureusement qu'on a encore
dit m lui c'est l'impôt moi c'est
l'ouverture à la concurrence vient le ça
n'est pas la privatisation c'est
simplement la possibilité pour que des
compagnies nouvelles viennent assurer
une qualité de service
si on a vu une ouverture à concurrentes
concurrence pour les navetteurs
on n'aurait pas la dégradation telle
qu'elle est j'aurais juste finir en 30
secondes sur ce sujet pas plus nous
devons rester impérativement un nouveau
système qui s'appelle taxi rails il ya
une société qui est en train de se
former pour mettre des voitures
autonomes sur les petites lignes qui
sont réservables à la demande
et bien ça c'est l'avenir ton aux
petites lignes on en a besoin pour la
mobilité des jeunes pour la mobilité des
travailleurs et j'étais avec le le
patron de cette société ce matin au
téléphone je vous assure que nous si
nous sommes élus demain nous irons dans
ce sens cette fois c'est vraiment de
lecture et un sacré flambeau est ce que
vous êtes favorable à l'ouverture à la
concurrence
oui je suis favorable raisonnablement
l'ouverture à la concurrence ça me
semble intéressant pour développer
justement les nos concitoyens au
beaucoup d'attentes
les collectivités n'ont pas les moyens
de répondre a toutefois d'être conscient
donc c'est tous ensemble public privé
qu'on peut leur proposer du mieux chaque
jour à la région c'est du quotidien il
faut qu'il le confrère me dire quoi
concrètement plus de train d'être un
gratuit oui ça veut dire plus de mick ça
veut dire plus de propositions notamment
tarifaires et donc si on veut plus de
gratuité d'un côté faut aussi peut-être
plus de deux offres payantes de l'autre
côté faut équilibrer les choses la
région c'est pas un puits sans fond il
ya un budget il est important mais il
faut aussi générer d'autres ressources
et ça passe aussi par la recherche du
privé et parmi les ressources l'éco taxe
vous êtes favorable ou pas je suis
favorable à la travailler je pense qu'un
appui peut être compris il peut etre
compris si un service enceinte et en
même temps d'auclair et renault ça peut
vous faire rigoler c'est pas grave je
voulais terminer là dessus les quotas
tous les ans je la mettrais au débat
juste pas je la déciderai je la mettrais
au débat parce qu'on peut l'appliquer
aussi avec des curseurs j'ai kiffé
protéger nos entreprises locales en
mettant les quotas qu'on vous a entendu
rien julien doute pourtant oui on voit
les marqueurs idéologiques de la gauche
éternel finalement toujours plus
d'impôts toujours plus de politique de
la ville toujours plus d'éoliennes tout
ce qui ne fonctionne pas dans notre pays
je tiens à rappeler quand même que ces
cinq dernières années la gauche
socialiste ses 279 millions d'euros
d'impôts supplémentaires pour les
automobilistes
avec la taxe sur les carburants au
taquet et avec l'augmentation de la
tarification pour la carte grise qui a
durement pénalisé les automobilistes
franc comtois c'est ça la politique de
la gauche et sur l'écotaxe monsieur
thuriau vous savez que les quotas qui
sacrifierait 30000 emplois notre
jean 30000 emplois et me rend pas ses
fils en démocratie avec le transport
route des monts stress moi évidemment
accueillir mais il faut des
bombardements contre cette politique
farouchement contre les éoliennes parce
qu'encore une fois cédé en forme on a
couru ici également
et puis sur cette obsession des impôts
des taxes
il faut un moratoire parce que nos
compatriotes n'en peuvent plus
marie-guite dufay sur un l'ouverture à
la concurrence s'il vous plaît et de
l'écotaxe oui et auparavant il y avait
la réponse à la halle auditrice sur le
cadencement vous avez raison et les
petites lignes
donc comme le cadencement nous avons
fait énormément énormément d'efforts
notamment sur la grande ligne belfort
besançon dijon alors dire qu'il ya
encore à faire
probablement on peut pas dire qu'on a
qu'on a tous fait je reconnais mais
franchement reconnaissez aussi si vous
prenez le train souvent que on a fait
beaucoup en matière de cadencement et
d'accroissement de l'offre sur cette
ligne très fréquentée par contre les
petites lignes
nous n'avons fermé aucune petite ligne
je le dis avec force dégradation du sens
en gens quand même régulièrement jamais
ça
on reviendra sur les fermetures de
petites lignes footing mais il n'y a pas
eu de faire du tir de peu du mal à
conclure si bien monsieur vrai c'est
important de dire qu'il n'ya pas eu de
fermeture de petites lignes jean selles
région alors sur l'ouverture à la
concurrence
j'y suis favorable la concurrence ce
n'est pas la privatisation
parce que la concurrence et mettre en
concurrence effectivement plusieurs
compagnies à partir d'un cahier des
charges qui est un cahier des charges de
ce que doit être service public et c'est
la région qui le décide c'est la région
qui dit quelle conception et la du
service public qui propose ce cahier des
charges comme ça se fait dans les villes
jean koe dit viens ne sont pas
aujourd'hui des services 3 ultra voyou
sur leur territoire et sur la mise en
place de l'éco tourisme dame du fis je
suis d'accord pour la mise en place de
l'écotaxe comme sur des sur des petites
distances sur des grandes distances pour
éliminer effectivement les transporteurs
locaux et faire en sorte que cette
ressource permettent justement de
travailler sur la décarbonation du
transport du transport merci madame du
fait on va passer
et on va vous demander de réagir à ce
sondage que nous avons publié sur france
télé ce matin sondage ipsos steria
auprès de 1000 personnes interrogées
entre les 3 et 7 juin
389 de ses mille personnes se sont
déclarées certaines d'aller voter vous
allez voir apparaître un qr code sur
votre téléviseur qui va vous permettre
de scanner le qr code pour aller sur
notre site internet et découvrir
l'intégralité des questions et des
réponses vous voyez les résultats
julien odoul basculerait en tête de ce
premier tour
28% suivi à égalité de gilles platret et
marie-guite dufay 21 1% chacun d'eux ni
thuriau la république est en marche 16%
ces trois listes seraient donc en
capacité de se maintenir au deuxième
tour
suivent ses quatre listes excusez-moi
suivent
stéphanie modde bastien faudot et claire
rocher et puis on va voir les intentions
de vote pour le second tour dans le
cadre d'une quadrangulaire
les quatre listes se maintiendrait donc
dans le cadre d'une quadrangulaire c'est
marie-guite dufay qui conserverait donc
la présidence de la région suivi de
julien odoul gilles platret et monsieur
thuriau jules julien odolant je vais me
tourner vers vous vous êtes en tête du
premier tour julien houdu le
rassemblement national est il prêt à
gouverner
à chaque fois que des élus rassemblement
national arrive dans des collectivités
les groupes d'élus explose ça a été le
cas au conseil régional ça a été le cas
dans de multiples municipalité ça a été
le cas aussi au conseil départemental de
l yonne
le rn est il prêt à gouverner s'il gagne
ça n'a pas été le cas à perpignan ou la
gestion de louis aliot est exemplaire
ça n'a pas été le cas hénin beaumont où
steeve briois été réélu au premier tour
à 75%
ça n'a pas été le cas à fréjus à
beaucaire ce n'a pas été le cas et
englobe donc encore monter encore donné
plein d'exemples qu une fois la gestion
municipale duras mot nationale est
exemplaire
nous rétablissons la sécurité moins
d'impôts pour les contribuables
un cadre de vie respecter une vie
culturelle qui se trouvent améliorées
tout ça c
politique du bon sens tout ça c'est la
politique des mers rarement nationale
c'est la politique que je souhaite mener
à la région avec plus de sécurité plus
de proximité plus de rééquilibrage
territorial parce qu'on en a très peu
parlé
on a une région qui est essentiellement
rural où tout était concentré pour la
métropole dijonnaise et moi je souhaite
un bouclier rural à chaque fois qu'il y
aura un euro pour la métropole de dijon
il y aura un euro pour les petites
communes puisqu'il ya un besoin
d'équilibrer les subventions j'ai encore
une fois je viens de vous êtes en tête
du premier tome et on l'a vu dans notre
sondage ne gagnait pas le deuxième tour
il va falloir peut-être rassembler pour
gagner vous avez tendu la main agile
plâtre et au cours de la campagne
est ce que votre main est toujours
tendue vous savez moi je tends la main à
tous les bourguignons les francs comtois
qui veulent l'alternance
je suis le seul avec ma liste avec mes
alliés de l'avenir français de la droite
populaire thierry mariani je suis le
seul à pouvoir faire gagner
l'alternance dans la région je suis le
seul à pouvoir mettre un terme à dix
cette année la gestion calamiteuse les
socialistes même donc je tends la main à
tout le monde et à gilles platret y
compris parce qu'encore une fois moi je
vois que gilles platret a fait encore
une fois un rassemblement avec l'ancien
premier ministre l'ancien explique le
premier liste de marine le pen nicolas
dupont-aignan sur bien des points nous
nous retrouvons évidemment
quel est l'objectif aujourd'hui pour les
électeurs aient l'air et moi je
m'adresse à eux plus qu'aux appareils
politiques
c'est évidemment de battre la gauche
c'est évidemment de battre macron je
suis le seul en capacité de le faire
donc il faut se rassembler dès le
premier tour si j'étais à créer la main
ou l'apprenez elle a besoin
écoutez bien ce que je vais vous dire
jamais jamais je ne travaillerais avec
quelqu'un qui est capable d'avoir
l'indignité de rigoler de la mort et du
suicide des agriculteurs ja mais ça
n'est pas une question parti politique
c'est une question de dignité
monsieur aux douleurs n'a fait preuve
hélas plus qu'il n'en faut donc il n'y
aura pas d'accord en revanche permettez
moi quand même de vous dire à tous les
deux que je suis très heureux de voir le
sondage ipsos mais qui ne vous a pas
échappé que ce matin j'ai publié un
autre sondage que nous avons fait
réaliser par l'ifop et qui ne donnent
pas exactement les mêmes résultats ni au
premier tour ni au deuxième tour je ne
met pas du tout en cause celui que vous
avez fait pas plus
bien je dis simplement une chose c'est
comme mon âme derrière long jeu
prestigieuse revue la période de
l'enquète est à peine différente nous le
nôtre est plus récent hier il ya trois
jours des cadres donc il ya trois jours
d'écart et surtout j'aurais été très
intéressés que vous sauviez l'hypothèse
d'une triangulaire car comme par hasard
elle n'apparaît pas dans les chiffres
que vous avez donnée chez moi elle
apparaît et on voit qu'on est serrée
dans un mouchoir de poche
si cette triangulaire se passe entre le
ps le rassemblement social et moi je
vais juste vous dire une chose pourquoi
est ce que les chiffres sont différents
à deux jours d'écart
tout simplement parce que nos
concitoyens sont en train de se demander
maintenant pour qui ils vont voter
nous sommes au moment où le choix se
fait donc laissons donc les électeurs
décidés ils seront bien plus fort que
nos sondages recevait prêt à prendre le
risque de perdre de laisser gagner la
gauche en nous alliant pas julian deux
je n'ai pas à répondre avec tout le
désagrément que j'en ai de ne pas
répondre directement à votre question
pourquoi parce que je conduis ma ligne
avec les alliés qui sont les miens et
que j'ai bien l'intention dans les dix
jours qu'il nous reste darriver autant
tête du premier tour et de m'imposer au
second mais encore une fois ce sont les
électeurs qui décideront nos campagnes
jusqu'au bout sur nos thèmes pour la
bourgogne et pour la franche-comté denis
thuriau si vous êtes quatrième du
premier tour comme l'indiquent notre
sondage est-ce que vous maintiendrez
pour le second tour ce sondage est
intéressant et inquiétant il est
intéressant parce qu'il nous donne une
dynamique nous sommes les seuls à avoir
pris des points depuis le dernier qui
avait été publié et il reste encore onze
jours de campagne donc on va aller
chercher puis votre émission va
peut-être nous y aider ensuite par
rapport à ceux votre question
marie-guite dufay avait dit lors d'un
salon d'innovation où elle était
présente que j'étais amer intelligent
dans une ville intelligente je saurai me
montrer intelligent je ne peux même vous
savez chez un mouvement de rassemblement
de la gauche à la droite à la droite
progressiste pas la droite souverainiste
et l'alliance avec debout la france qui
pour moi est rédhibitoire la ligne rouge
donc il ya déjà des tas de gens de
gauche de droite y compris dlr qui nous
rejoint suite à l'alliance qu'a choisi
monsieur platret debout la france donc
finalement c'est assez naturellement je
discute avec tout le monde sauf les
extrêmes et notamment l'extrême droite
et jeudi inquiétant parce qu'il faut que
nos électeurs sachent que si l'extrême
droite prenez cette région
il en serait de l'avenir de leurs
enfants et petits-enfants danger
attention danger alors choix attention
danger
marie-guite dufay vous êtes patatras
discuter avec tout le monde y compris
avec la république en marche
moi je suis prête à rassembler ma
famille à sa gauche
ma famille elle est à gauche seul est
déjà en partie rassemblés avec leurs
énergies et avenir du parti communiste
et je souhaite effectivement la
rassembler avec les autres alliés les
écologistes et le reste de la gauche
c'est mon objectif c'est mon obsession
parce que je pense que dans cette région
c'est la gauche à la différence d'autres
régions c'est la gauche rassemblée qui
est laurent pagny d'uriage de nurieux
vient d'un gauche et au parti socialiste
mais je ne ne répond pas à cette
question denis thuriau il est en marche
moi je vous parle pas des images en
appel du pied sur cette scène donc on
vous pouvez lui répond je fais que du 42
e mail ce n'est pas besoin d'appel du
pied
mon objectif c'est le rassemblement de
la gauche aujourd'hui et c'est un peu
face et même largement la raison de mon
de mon existence de marie dissimulation
à ce scrutin c'est la gauche rassemblée
contre le rassemblement national jusqu'à
bastia en photo oui non non je vous pose
la question si vous aviez bien
évidemment exclusive dans une famille
stephen c'était oui bah ou bastien photo
oui répond des basses-terres faudoas
pour acquis et même du feu monsieur
thuriau les et en plus je n'ai pas
entendu que les alliances qui se forme
sur cette scène donc comment maintenant
écoutez moi les choses sont claires
depuis le départ depuis le départ au
temps des cerises nous rassemblant neuf
organisations politiques le sondage ne
nous a pas donné pleine satisfaction ce
matin au réveil comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer des des siens mais enfin
jusqu ici il ya eu des sondages qui nous
donnaient entre 7 et 10 11% en bon juste
une précision c'est le premier sondage
commandé par un média les sondages
auxquels vous faites tous référence les
précédents s'étaient commandé par
différents partis politiques
oui m'enfin les sondeurs ont le même
qu'on me le même type les sondeurs ont
le même type de travail je veux pas
rentrer dans la technique mais en tout
état de cause il doit une oblique à une
obligation de netteté
or au travail de sondage alors
évidemment le sujet central pour nous et
ce sondage démontre comme tous les
précédents c'est que s'il y a un bloc
constitué avec l'ensemble de la gauche
et des écologistes
alors on pourra maintenir cette région
dans des politiques et des objectifs de
progrès pour l'ensemble des bourguignons
et des franc comtois
c'est ça l'enjeu central le reste vous
voyez on voit les porosités qui peuvent
exister à droite quand j'entends le
discours aurait pu faire un premier tour
par dont vous avez pu faire mais il se
trouve qu'il y à un certain nombre de
désaccords qui ont pu s'exprimer vous le
savez et ils ont été dit clairement
qu'on ne s'en est jamais caché nous on
défend l'idée et la ligne d' une gauche
sincère qui doit servir dans un
rassemblement aussi elle est sincère
mais je ne te ciblait pas
particulièrement dollar est vite en
disant ce titre est la question centrale
c'est comment on fait pour que
l'orientation des politiques publiques
soient renforcées en matière de
transition énergétique
nous l'avons dit dans le débat tout à
l'heure mais aussi en matière de
politique sociale et de redressement
industriel dans la région stéphanie
modde est-ce que vous inscrivez dans
cette future union large de la gauche
des gens un mot sur sur la raisons pour
lesquelles nous nous avons souhaité
vraiment avoir une liste écologiste au
premier tour c'était pour porter un
projet écologiste fort que j'ai pu
entendre ce soir sur le tout sur le
pathos et effectivement des divergences
de fond on a bien entendu dont le
rassemblement national c'est c'est la
sécurité qui n'est pas une compétence
région c'est la vidéosurveillance qui
coûteront qui coûterait extrêmement cher
mais ça c'est pas du tout budgétisé ya
aucune idée aucun projet économique
la droite a bien c'est la droite
effectivement c'est la droite qui a
démontré les services publics c'est la
droite qui veut toujours plus de
libéralisme la république en marche et
vince effectivement c'est c'est la
convention citoyenne katyn là bas donc
c'est effectivement une politique aussi
de droite au niveau national comme au
niveau régional donc effectivement nous
nous irons dans un dans une vaste liste
de fusion parce que nous souhaitons
qu'elle région reste à gauche avec les
écologistes pour porter un projet
écologiste for in justice sociale encore
plus forte
voilà donc dans ce dans ce cadre là
effectivement nous envisagerons si tous
les éléments sont réunis et je pense que
nous pourrons le faire en bonne
intelligence au sein du support au sort
du 1er tour savoir nous réunir
parce que effectivement la région
bourgogne franche comté a vraiment
besoin d'avoir une gouvernance forte
ancré à gauche écologistes on l'a
compris une alliance oui avec la gauche
non avec la république en marche ça vous
dérange pas que marie-guite dufay et
voté en faveur d' emmanuel macron à la
présidentielle en 2017
vous l'avez dit il ya des gens quitter à
gauche qui sont passés à droite moi le
passé s'est passé ce qui m'intéresse
c'est ce qui se passe actuellement ce
sont les engagements qui sont pris
actuellement nous discuterons des
engagements qui seront pris
marie-guite dufay on vous fait est ce
que c'est un handicap ça ce vote vous
portez on a l'impression parfois comme
un fardeau
ce vote pour emmanuel un accord pas du
tout non pas du tout je moi c'est la
sincérité qui me guide
quand on me pose la question j'aurais pu
l'éviter et je me serais éviter c'est
moi de vous la pause la fameuse séquence
qui tourne à 50 ans le micro pays bon
donc je répond sincèrement je vois une
nouvelle personnalité sur la place
publique dans notre pays effectivement
et qui me séduit absolument je suis pas
sûr que dans cette salle 1 au milieu de
nous tous beaucoup comme moi il eu le
livre qu'avait écrit emmanuel macron à
ce moment là révolution et j'ai trouvé
dans ce livre des choses qui me parlait
énormément en termes de sécurisation
professionnelle en termes de formation
et c'est vraiment beaucoup cela qui m'a
guidé et aujourd'hui il ya le tueur ou
pas non j'ai dit depuis je suis je suis
quand il ya des choses qui sont bien
faites au niveau du gouvernement je le
dit et il y en a quand il y en a que je
ne partage pas je le dis également c'est
pas tout blanc ou tout noir
il faut avoir le courage de la nuance sa
gelée chevillée au corps donc c'est pas
tout blanc ou tout noir on est pour on
est contre macron à ça doit aussi dit le
effectivement les politiques plutôt
social qui sont conduites aujourd'hui au
niveau du gouvernement
je ne peux absolument pas y adhérer la
dernière en date étant autour de
l'assurance chômage
mais avant il ya eu la fin des apl avant
il ya eu la fin des emplois aidés tout
cela je ne peux absolument pas y habiter
general electric on peut en rajouter
j'aimerais somme des verts qui
approchera dans les conclusions à la fin
d'émission arrive car rocher à vous êtes
qualité dans notre sondage de 2% des
intentions de vote est ce que c'est pas
frustrant est ce que c'est pas
décourageant de voir que votre message
il imprime pas depuis plusieurs années
pas du tout alors vous savez s'il ya une
chose que je sais c'est que la situation
sociale
elle peut évoluer très vite et beaucoup
plus vite que les sondages et c'est que
le reflet d'un instant t et ils ont pas
tant de valeur que ça mais surtout la la
crise elle va s'approfondir et les
classes populaires sont pas encore
sorties et ma conviction c'est que les
ouvriers n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot
et c'est cette perspective que je veux
mettre en avant alors on arrive à la fin
de cette émission une dernière question
à chacun d'entre vous en guise de
conclusion
pourquoi faut-il voter pour vous vous
avez chacun 50 secondes et le tirage au
sort vous a désigné gilles platret pour
entamer ce dernier tour de pas de talent
mais ce dernier tour de scène d'abord
merci pour l'organisation de ce débat
beaucoup de thèmes n'ont pas été abordés
moi je voulais finir sur deux je vais
finir comme ça je vais pas dire je suis
le meilleur voté pour moi parce que ça
en l'entente depuis des décennies ça n'a
rien changé
la santé on est on est pour une
politique de terrain nous voulons que la
désertification médicale devienne une
grande cause régionale et donc nous
mettrons les moyens pour remettre des
médecins fusse-t-il salariés sur le
territoire là où il manque pour que dans
tout le territoire urbain comme rural on
trouve de quoi se soigner c'est un
impératif absolument absolue avec
l'accompagnement la perte de mobilité de
nos seniors
et puis le dernier thème celle équilibre
rural urbain
nous avons une région essentiellement
rural il faut aider les villes je vais
pas vous dire le contraire mais il faut
demain que l' équilibre se fasse et
notamment que nous aidions ceux qui
travaillent dans la ruralité en
particulier les agriculteurs que nous
avons vraiment l'intention d'accompagner
dans des périodes très compliqués qu'ils
vivent ce matin j'étais avec un des
éleveurs qui a subi une perte de
dizaines de brebis parce qu'on laisse le
loup dans les zones d'élevage
donc on a un vrai enjeu de proximité on
ira avec ceux qui connaissent le terrain
j'ai cité les chasseurs tout à l'heure
je cite tous ceux qui veulent s'investir
sans a priori politique
je suis en dehors des débats de la
gauche je les entends mais ne
m'intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse c'est
l'avenir des bourguignons et des franc
comtois claire rocher pour lutte
ouvrière fait à bout pourquoi faut-il
voter pour vous vous l'avez vu depuis
des années les sondages me crédite de 1
à 2% et bien je remercie ceux qui votent
pour moi même s'ils sont minoritaires
pour leur fidélité
quant aux travailleurs qui ne votent pas
encore pour mon programme je leur fais
confiance car je reste convaincu qu'au
delà de la confiance qu'ils font encore
aux dirigeants politiques et économiques
de notre société
il reste par instinct méfiants à l'égard
de l'arrogance de ces possédants et je
sais qu'un jour on se retrouvera dans le
même camp j'en ai l intime conviction et
j'invite les travailleurs qui en sont
convaincus comme moi à faire entendre le
camp des travailleurs en votant et en
faisant voter pour la liste d'ouvrières
claire rocher
bastien photo c'est à vous votre
conclusion s'il vous plaît 50 secondes
oui en votant pour le temps des cerises
vous voterez vous choisirez la clarté et
je suis en mesure de vous dire dès ce
soir ce que nous ferons et au soir du
premier tour
et pour la suite du mandat avec nous il
n'y aura aucune transaction aucun
compromis avec la république en marche
ou avec la droite pour faire barrage au
rassemblement national pour une raison
simple les politiques libérales ne sont
pas un rempart contre le rassemblement
national et jenson le pont levis donc
l'enjeu pour nous c'est de rassembler
toute la gauche et les écologistes mais
rien que la gauche et les écologistes et
je tendrais donc la main à toute la
gauche et aux écologistes
chaque bulletin glissé dans l'urne pour
le temps des cerises le 20 juin prochain
sera un bulletin pour l'union de la
gauche est pour la victoire de la gauche
le jaune contre n'est pas un projet le
vote le vrai vote utile c'est celui qui
est utile pour la relocalisation de
notre économie pour la bifurcation
écologique
merci la défense de nos services publics
merci bastien photo je lui en donne je
me tourne vers vous qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez dire ce soir aux bourguignons
et au franc comtois qui nous regardent
vous avez 5
souvent la plupart de mes adversaires
font campagne contre le rassemblement
national
moi je fais campagne pour les
bourguignons et pour les franc comtois
les bourguignons et les francs comtois
ont une chance historique faire gagner
l'alternance dans notre région cette
chance historique s'appelle le bulletin
de vote
rassemblement national le candidat ait
l'air est incapable de gagner face à la
candidate sortante
il ne le peut pas d'ailleurs il est très
ambigu il a voté comme la gauche 17
millions d'euros de subventions pour la
formation des migrants il a voté les
subventions pour le développement de
l'éolien dans la région il nous dit
qu'ils protègent les agriculteurs alors
que l air vient de voter au parlement
européen un projet pour interdire la
critique des traités de libre échange
qui pénalise nos agriculteurs le vote
d'alternance le vote utile le vote pour
gagner c'est le rassemblement national
et je le dis tous mes adversaires ont
échoué la gauche a échoué
la droite a échoué c'est notre tour
c'est votre tour
merci julien houdu marie-guite dufay
votre conclusion
comme chacun 50 secondes pour conclure
je veux tout simplement continuer à
incarner le volontarisme pour concilier
le développement des solidarités et le
développement économique dans un
contexte compliqué parce qu'on est face
à des mutations de toutes sortes qui
inquiète mutations économiques
écologiques numérique
cela nécessite beaucoup de travail
beaucoup d' écoute beaucoup de partage
beaucoup d'humilité aussi je me sens
prête avec tous mes alliés de gauche
déjà rassemblées pour ce premier tour le
ps le prg le parti communiste et demain
tout le reste de la famille de gauche
parce que je le redis dans cette région
il n'y a que la gauche qui peut faire
barrage au front national
merci marie-guite dufay stéphanie modde
même question que tous les autres vous
avez 50 secondes
pourquoi les bourguignons pourquoi les
francs comtois doivent-ils voter pour
vous nous faisons face à différentes
crises crise sanitaire déjà crise
écologique qui ne s'est pas arrêtée avec
la crise sanitaire crise économique et
les écologistes sont ceux qui peuvent
actuellement répondre à l'ensemble de
ces défis avec des solutions d'avenir
mon ambition c'est d'aller plus vite et
plus loin mettre tous les moyens
nécessaires pour vous accompagner dans
vos façons de travailler de vous
déplacer d'habiter de vous nourrir la
région écologiste est une région qui
protège c'est une région qui crée du
lien social
c'est une région qui n'est pas dans la
défiance ne sont pas des habitants qui
sont dans les défiances mais dans la
confiance c'est pourquoi nous avons pas
le temps d'aborder l'agriculture
paysanne et je trouve que vraiment
monsieur ollioules s'il y avait la
moindre descente ne parlerai pas
d'agriculteurs mais c'est l'agriculture
paysanne économie circulaire le réemploi
qui fait que si vous votez pour notre
liste
oui vrai pour vivre mieux en bourgogne
franche comté donc merci de voter le 20
juin pour la liste écologiste et
solidaire que j'ai l'honneur de mener
merci stéphanie modde et enfin denis
thuriau votre conclusion comme chacun 50
secondes pour conclure vous avez
l'occasion d'écrire une nouvelle page de
la bourgogne franche comté une des rares
régions en france qui perd des habitants
qui perd de l'économie qui perdent des
emplois pour ça il faut une région plus
accompagnatrice plus présente dans les
tout petits territoires les plus
fragiles donc halte aux dogmes halte au
sectarisme qui se sont révélés qu'ont
entendu d'un côté comme de l'autre de
l'ancien clivages politiques
tout ceci fait que vous n'avez pas
besoin d'une région d'une autre gauche
qui s'est radicalisée d'une gauche à
gauche de la gauche d'une ultra droite
qui a fait alliance avec debout la
france qui est le partenaire naturel du
rassemblement national et pas besoin non
plus d'une région rassemblement national
qu'il mettrait à l'index qui nous
fermerait des fonds européens et qui
anéantirait tout espoir de développement
et pour cela nous proposons justement
une liste unie une liste qui rassemble
et donc une liste qui vous ressemble
notre arc politique il peut devenir
votre arc en ciel voter le numéro 4 la
région partout et pour tous merci denis
thuriau un petit mot jérémy on va
peut-être refaire le point redonner le
consommateur de france may well notre
sondage que vous pouvez consulter sur
notre site internet on vous donne ce
soir les intentions de vote mais y ait
énormément d'autres questions que vous
pouvez voir sur notre site les
intentions de vote pour le 1er tour
sondage ipsos steria pour france
télévisions auprès d'eux
les lecteurs de bourgogne franche comté
vous allez voir le premier tour voilà
julien au dos le gilles platret
marie-guite dufay denis thuriau
stéphanie modde bastien faudot et claire
rocher dans cet ordre pour le premier
tour et l'hypothèse quadrangulaire pour
le second tour dans l'ordre marie-guite
dufay julien odoul gilles platret et
denis thuriau n'hésitez pas à consulter
l'ensemble de ce sondage sur notre site
internet
évidemment il ne s'agit que d'un sondage
rien n'est joué il reste une dizaine de
jours pour faire campagne on vous
souhaite à tous les c'est une bonne fin
de campagne
et merci merci à tous les êtres d'avoir
accepté de venir débattre ce soir ici
merci aussi au palais des congrès de
beaune qui nous a permis d'organiser ce
débat la campagne des élections
évidemment c'est à suivre sur france 3
bourgogne et france 3 franche comté
chaque soir dans nos éditions une page
spéciale et puis des débats des débats
sur les départementales en début de
semaine prochaine ce sera avec 4e série
et gabrielle talon des débats encore et
toujours sur les régionales ce sera
dimanche avec vous jérémy latine
10h55 précisément vous allez vous
intéresser une compétence essentielle du
conseiller général conomie on fera une
heure sur l'économie et puis bien sûr
nos soirées électorales
le dimanche 20 et 27 juin à partir de 20
heures nous serons ensemble sur france 3
et puis un grand rendez-vous retrouvera
les finalistes justement du premier tour
pour un nouveau débat ce sera ici même à
beaune au palais des congrès ce sera
jeudi 24 juin à 18 heures merci de votre
fidélité merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous tous merci jérémy merci
thomas pour france bleu passé une
première soirée sur france 3 et 10 de la
politique merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]